now here's a tough question uh
for you know from the computer science
perspective we often over optimize
so you create processes and you
okay just like you're saying it's so
pleasurable
to increase in the long-term
productivity
that sometimes you just enjoy that
process in itself yeah by just creating
processes
and you actually never uh
like it has a negative effect on
productivity long term because you're
too obsessed with the processes
is that is that uh a nice problem to
have essentially
i mean it's a problem i mean because
let's look at the one sector that does
do this which is
uh developers yeah right so agile
methodologies like scrum or kanban
are basically workflow methodologies
that are much better than the
hyperactive hive mine
but man some of those programmers get
pretty obsessive i don't know if you've
ever talked to a whatever
level three scrum master they get really
obsessive
about like it has to happen exactly this
way and it's probably seven times more
complex than it needs to be
i'm hoping that's just because nerds
like me you know
like to do that but it's it's a a
broadly probably an issue right we have
to be careful because you can just go
down that
that fiddling path like so it needs to
be here's how we do it let's reduce the
messages and let's roll
you know um you can't save yourself
through if you can get the process just
right right
so i wrote this article kind of recently
called the rise and fall of getting
things done
and i profiled this productivity guru
named merlin mann and i talked about
this movement called productivity prawn
as like elite speak term in the early
2000s where people just became
convinced that if they could combine
their productivity systems with software
and they could find just the right
software just the right configuration
where they could offload most of the
difficulty of work what happened
with the machines when kind of figured
out four and then they could just sort
of crank widgets and be
and the whole thing fell apart because
it work is hard and it's hard to do and
making decisions about what to work on
is hard
and no system can really do that for you
so you have to have this
this sort of balance between i uh
contact switches are poison so we gotta
get rid of the context which is once
like something's working good enough to
get rid of the context switches then
get after it yeah there's a
psychological process there for me and
the ocd nature like i've literally
embarrassingly enough have lost my [ __ ]
before when
uh so in in many of the processes that
involve python scripts
the rule is to not use spaces
underscore zone there's like rules for
like how you format stuff okay
and like i should not lose my [ __ ] when
somebody
had a space and maybe capital letters
like it's okay to have a space i think
because because there's
this feeling like something is not
perfect yeah
and uh as opposed to in the python
script allowing some flexibility around
that
you create this programmatic way that's
flawless and when everything's working
perfectly it's
perfect but actually if you strive for
perfection
it has the same stress like has a lot of
the stress that you were seeking to
escape with the contact switching yeah
because you're almost
stressing about errors like when the
process is functioning
you're there's always this anxiety of
like i wonder if it's gonna
succeed yeah i wonder if it's gonna
succeed yeah no no i think some of
that's just you and i probably i mean
it's just our mindset right we're in we
do computer science
right so chicken and egg yeah and a lot
of the
processes end up working here are much
rougher it's like okay instead of
letting clients just
email me all the time we have a weekly
call
and then we send them a breakdown of
everything we committed to
right that's a process that works okay i
get asked a lot of questions because i'm
the javascript guy in the company
accepting it by email i have office
hours this is what basecamp does all
right so you come to my office hours
that cuts down a lot of back and forth
all right we're gonna instead of
emailing about this project we'll have a
trello board and we'll do a weekly
really structured status meeting real
quick what's going on who needs what
let's go
and now everything's on there and on our
inboxes we'll have to send as many
messages so like that rough level of
granularity
that gets you most of the way there
you